i am very sorry about cowboy not getting
another season
but
uh but you've landed on your feet
getting to work with a coen brother and
macbeth so let's you know i think i
think you're good
so i have a lot of questions um i when i
was researching preparing to talk to you
i read that one like your first movie
role was in cold mountain as like an
orderly if i'm not mistaken um what was
it like uh what do you remember about
making that movie and getting to be in
like a big movie like that
i largely remember really embarrassing
myself in a bunch of different ways i'd
never been on a film set well i'd hardly
been on a set at all but certainly
nothing of that magnitude
and um one of my
abiding memories
was that i had to play an orderly and i
had to carry someone on a stretcher in a
really important sort of sad scene with
jude law and lucas black
and we had to be walking up a
steep incline all day and i had his head
at my end tonight and i'm not a
particularly big guy i was much less
than
less big then and there were all these
extras that were army constricts scripts
doing the same thing over and over
anyway at the end of the day i just
couldn't hold this this um stretcher
anymore but i didn't want to say
anything i didn't want to sort of expose
it i was weak so in a shot i just it
slipped out of my hands and lucas fell
to the floor and the stretcher snapped
in half he landed on his mic there's
this horrifying silence and i just went
sorry sorry sorry sorry
and they cut and i was just really
really embarrassed and then and then a
couple of days later i was talking you
know very lucky enough to be in the
company of jude law and anthony miguela
and i think maybe even sydney pollock
was there at the time too and we were
covered in blood fake blood which is
made of sugar and a wasp got into my ear
but no one saw this wasp get into my ear
so in the middle of the conversation i
was just like freaking out like this it
was terrible i mean largely i just
embarrassed myself
hopefully i've got better on sets since
then but it wasn't a great start
uh thank you for sharing those that's
some great stuff um obviously like like
like everyone you're a fan of the coen
brothers and joel cohen and i'm just
curious what was it like actually
sitting down with him for the first time
getting how did you get cast in this and
was a little bit nerve-wracking sitting
across from someone who's such a gifted
filmmaker
what is so amazing about joel is that
he's incredibly personable so any um
sort of
nerves and excitement i mean great
excitement on my part but nerves
instantly kind of disappear because he's
just such a like a down-to-earth normal
guy
he just has a great deal of experience
genius
and more talent than um
many people put together but he makes
you feel very at home and i think that's
part of his gift as a director is that
he relaxes you without even trying i
think and it means that you
explore
further reaches of a character or of an
idea of a scene than you might with
other directors because you feel very
held by him
in terms of being cast
i was lucky enough to be cast by ellen
chenoweth who cast this in a film called
suburbicon
so she knew my work and she'd seen me as
henry the fifth in fact so i think she
must have remembered that i did
shakespeare and i auditioned for harry
melling's part in um the ballad of
buster scruggs doing a bit of
shakespeare on tape so i maybe you know
she remembered that too
and i just basically made a tape
for joel and um and i don't really know
why me as opposed to anyone else but i'm
very pleased that um
that was the case they couldn't find
anyone else to fit into the costume
maybe i'm not sure
i think it could be you may you might
have some talent you know just a little
um i try
uh what was your reaction though
stepping on set for the first time and
seeing
the the uh the fact that it was all
gonna be on sound stages that he was
gonna be filming in black and white you
know the aesthetical the aesthetic
choices he made for the production
it was all just immensely exciting and
they they
it all just made sense
when you
i mean he's created a real end to end
realized visual world and kind of
approach in this film and that is very
rare i've not been part of something
really that
is so kind of hermetically sealed in its
own thing in the way that this film is
um and it just makes knowing the play
very well i've directed the play and
know very well it just makes perfect
sense for this for this story um
and
i
you you get a sense on set often that
something is interesting um but you
never know how it's going to turn out
but it really just everything i saw was
was made me very excited and hopeful
about what it'd be like when it came
together and then
when i you know when i saw the whole
thing as an audience member and as a
cohen's fan as a fan of cinema and of
shakespeare i think it's a really
brilliant version of this film and a
really brilliant film you know i'm very
very honoured and grateful to be part of
it
i loved bruno cinematography and at
times it reminded me a little bit of
like german expressionism you know with
the way it was shot can you sort of talk
about working with bruno
bruno also is a lovely man i mean this
is the thing when you get to work with
people at this level they you know joel
they've collected
the people that they like to work with
most and um
bruno is a very collaborative open warm
person too and works very very hard we
moved very fast we didn't have very long
to shoot this um so we shot a lot of
setups in the day
so you know bruno really had to run
around
um he never
sort of told us what to do even though
you could tell that
it was a very pictorial composed you
know visual piece
um
and i just think he's done amazing work
as you say german expressionism bergman
um kurosawa uh there are so many amazing
references what i love about the film is
it it's sort of set in the history of
shakespearean cinema in a weird way um
that i think is
makes it even more otherworldly
what do you think it is
i'm just curious shakespeare has
obviously been adapted and re-adapted in
so many different versions what do you
think it is about shakespeare's writing
that has resonated with people for
hundreds of years and everyone keeps
going back to it
i think there's a number of factors i
think he writes or sort of pillaged
really really good stories
but then
he
is just so perceptive about human nature
i think um
about people's wants and desires about
the underbelly of
uh of
those desires i think what one it might
be willing to do
for what you think is a good thing or
something that you think is important to
you
and
then he
writes those stories and those ideas in
such incredibly dense
language that can be
interpretable
infinitely in that it's so complicated
that you can't land on the right way of
doing it or
one way of doing it it's too big and
therefore you can as an actor you can in
the same part over hundreds of
performances find new stuff in it even
as the same actor let alone a bunch of
different actors playing the same part
that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say congrats on being part of this film
and getting to work with you know uh
joel and everybody else and i wish you
nothing but the best
thanks man hope to see you again really
soon i hope so as well thank you so much
for your time man